we have yet another former Trump staffer
saying this is serious and Trump may end
up in prison here is Mick Mulvaney
Donald Trump's own former Chief of Staff
previous to uh Mark Meadows saying Trump
indeed may end up doing prison time I
don't even agree with this but this is
Mick Mulvaney himself saying it if
Donald Trump had done what Joe Biden did
here what Mike Pence did here when they
found their classified documents they
gave them back and there's no charges
against Pence there's not going to be
charges against Biden the difference
here is what Trump did to try and cover
up what he did in the first place I said
so often the case it's not the
underlying crime it's the interference
it's the cover-up that gets folks in
trouble and they have him with
significant evidence it looks like as to
obstruction so I think the chances of a
of a guilty verdict are fairly High and
the chances of of real jail time are
pretty high and when you say real jail
time how long might that be
uh well at his age it doesn't really
make much difference right I think the
maximum if you add up all the math the
maximum could be over 500 years the
minimum would be a hundred years
I don't even think I agree with Mick
Mulvaney and I've said all along I don't
believe Donald Trump will do a day of
prison time period however I will say
that over the last 72 hours
I have moved ever so slightly in the
direction of maybe maybe there will be
some jail time for Trump it's it's I I'm
now in the realm of before I was in
absolutely no way in hell
after speaking to a couple of lawyers
reading through the indictment reading
uh about the law around the allegations
for which Trump is going to be charged
looking at a few different things I am
now I've moved from no way in hell Trump
does prison time two it is extremely
unlikely but possible that Trump ends up
with something it could however end up
being one of these well he will serve it
at his house with an ankle monitor which
by the way I would still accept at this
point in time all right so Mick Mulvaney
also now on the list of former Trump
staffers who says this is serious and
Trump could be toast to quote William
Barr we'll see who else comes out of the
woodwork